now some breaking news reaching us here
at Sky News Center that the fashion
designer Dame Vivian Westwood has died
at the age of 81. in a statement on
Twitter her fashion house said that she
died peacefully and surrounded by her
family and Clapham in South London well
let's get to the latest with Sky
correspondent Sadia chadri joins me now
and Sadia Dan Vivian of course best
known for the punk years and her
collaborations with Malcolm McLaren
yes she is considered a fashion royalty
isn't she uh Vivian Westwood who sadly
died at the age of 82 today she is
someone that is considered to have
shaken up the industry to have really
pioneered
um punk fashion she's someone uh who
pioneered the punk fashion scene in the
1980s and she brought together uh modern
punk and a New Wave fashion which is
really her Legacy a lot of people would
have seen some of her
items on the catwalk and thought this
isn't something that can come into
mainstream but she managed to deliver it
she was
um someone who designed clothes for
celebrities and royalty princess Eugenie
wore one of Vivian Westwood's um
ensembles to Prince William and Kate
Middleton's wedding she also designed
clothes for music stars and rock stars
uh Pharrell Williams among them
um her designs featured in films
including the 2008 film adaptation of
the TV series Sex and the City but she
really came into prominence
um when she opened a boutique on Kings
Road in London with
um the manager of the Sex Pistols
Malcolm McLaren as you say
um but she's also someone who is
considered an activist she she was never
one to just stick to Fashion she stepped
into Politics as well she's a keen
supporter of the green party reportedly
donating 300 000 pounds to them at one
point she's someone that believed in
sustainable fashion long before
sustainable fashion became fashionable
and she was also a supporter of Julian
Assange the founder of WikiLeaks as she
visited him several times in the
Ecuadorian Embassy when he was there but
you know she is someone who is
considered royalty she's a big big name
in British fashion a real Pioneer of the
punk scene uh of the 1980s and someone
who you know really started that not
just with our store in Kings Road but
which then became the Hub of the punk
scene but someone who uh has a long
lasting Legacy and I'll just uh read out
to you a tweet from her fashion house uh
Vivian with Westwood which said 29th of
December Vivian Westwood died today
peacefully and surrounded by her family
in Clapham South London the world needs
people like Vivian to make change for
the better and that's Vivian Westwood
who died at the age of 81 today